y llegó la hora de hablar de economía en
france 24 nuestro periodista
especializado jorge hurtado está con
nosotros jorge bienvenido y empecemos
hablando en europa porque comenzó el
liderazgo o la lucha por el liderazgo en
la producción de chips así es mar clara
y bueno es que por su lado controla jean
quien es presidenta de la comisión
europea anunció el día de hoy la ley
europea para la creación de chips
anticipándose a futuros problemas de
suministros la funcionaria europea dijo
que la unión europea prevé movilizar 45
mil millones de euros en inversiones
hasta 2030 para cuadriplicar su
producción de chips esenciales para la
fabricación de dispositivos electrónicos
como teléfonos móviles lavadoras
maquinaria industrial y la fabricación
de vehículos
el objetivo es concentrar el 20 por
ciento de la producción de chips del
mundo para ello tendrían que multiplicar
por cuatro su fabricación en la
actualidad tengo ni corea del sur son
responsables de más de la mitad de la
producción global mientras que la unión
europea es el líder mundial en
investigación y maquinaria para producir
chips escuchamos que decía la presidenta
de la comisión europea el día de hoy
nos hemos fijado el objetivo de tener en
2030 el 20 por ciento de la cuota de
mercado mundial de producción de chips
aquí en europa ahora mismo estamos en el
9% queremos llegar al 20 por ciento en
2030 pero sabiendo que la demanda y el
mercado mundial se duplicarán durante
ese tiempo significa básicamente
cuadruplicar nuestros esfuerzos con you
plane effects y ahora vamos a eeuu donde
recuperaron una millonaria suma que se
habían robado de bitcoins así es el
departamento de justicia de ese país
anunció que había recuperado más de
94.000 bits con robados en 2016 el robo
fue de 120 mil bitcoins por un hackeo a
la empresa bitcoin ex entonces la suma
robada fue de 71 millones de dólares
pero con las ganancias al día de hoy eso
asciende a más de 4 mil 500 millones de
dólares de estos el departamento de
justicia recuperó 3600 millones de
dólares en bitcoin robados y lee a
liechtenstein y su esposa hitler morgan
de 34 31 años fueron detenidas en nueva
york ahora podrían enfrentar hasta 20
años de prisión por lavado de dinero los
acusados retiraron parte del dinero en
cajeros bitcoin y usaban alphabet
marketplace que cerró en 2017 también
compraron oro e incluso una tarjeta de
regalo en walmart el departamento de
justicia dijo que se trata de la
incautación financiera más grande de la
historia escuchemos
esta es la mayor incautación de cripto
divisas jamás realizada por las fuerzas
de seguridad estadounidenses también es
la mayor incautación financiera del
departamento en su historia el mensaje a
los delincuentes es claro la cripto
moneda no es un refugio seguro podemos y
lo haremos seguir el dinero sin importar
la forma que tome
y en venezuela hubo protestas por una
reforma fiscal de qué se trata así se
trata de la ley de impuestos a las
grandes transacciones financieras según
la federación de cámaras y asociaciones
de comercio y producción de venezuela
la nueva ley impone una voracidad fiscal
que impedirá el camino hacia la
recuperación económica fedecámarás
denunció que no pudo hacer observaciones
durante el periodo de consulta previo a
la aprobación de la ley los empresarios
aseguran que los más afectados son el
sector bursátil y agrícola así como
algunos ciudadanos naturales escuchamos
y básicamente nos referimos al tema de
la voracidad fiscal que se ha venido
expresando de diferentes manifestaciones
manifestaciones a nivel local a través
de una serie de ordenanzas y alcaldías
que se han salido inclusive de el
esquema de ordenación tributaria o
secuestren los cuales son los
indicadores del día bueno wall street
cerró en verdes con todos sus
indicadores con ganancias del 1 06 por
ciento en su principal referente el down
down de industriales en europa el dax 40
de fráncfort cerró en verde pese a la
caída de los valores tecnológicos por
las expectativas de subida de los tipos
de interés en eeuu y en la zona del euro
y en américa latina la bolsa de sao
paulo en brasil avanzó impulsada por el
exterior y por la banca privada jorge y
la cifra del día bueno tiene que ver con
pzifer que espera que en 2022 las ventas
de su vacuna y antiviral contra el 19
superen los 54 mil millones de dólares
pero no alcanzó las estimaciones de wall
street y sus acciones bajaron alrededor
3 gracias jorge por toda la información
económica en france 24 y a ustedes los
invitamos a que consulten nuestra página
web france24 puntocom allí encontrarán
mucha más información nos vemos en
minutos
[Música]